and I love the industry and I love what
I do
um but when you start really young I
think it's kind of healthy to to have
some time away yeah I would say because
it's just a constant you know when
you're in the the you you've never
really had that sort of
sort of regular life constant if you
start that young yeah that is a good
thing to have at some point I didn't
know you started so young I mean
I I think I probably would have gone
absolutely insane I'm a very immature
person and if um you know I didn't get
my first big thing Smallville toll I was
like
27 yeah or something yeah but that was
like the big break and yeah I think that
hit me when I was nine right ten or even
15s 18 yeah I I would lose my mind I
wouldn't know what to do I didn't have
the maturity I didn't have the
wherewithal I didn't I I probably would
have gotten some trouble yeah and uh all
of those things I think I'm I think I've
ticked every box that you just mentioned
but really yeah oh sure it's inevitable
I mean it's inescapable and it's okay
there's ways of of getting through all
that but it's inescapable it's it's you
know as a director I've worked with kids
a lot and I always have and I talk to a
lot of moms you know they're always like
you know what should we do like you went
through it and I was like well you could
just pull them out you know yeah right
you're serious that's the safest thing
you could do is you could pull them out
but if you're going to keep men then
you've got to be all over it because
it's a lot yeah for kids that young I
gotta say This is Gonna Come Off weird
you might take you might be upset with
me there's no weird question I'm honest
to God I don't envy you I'm glad I had a
childhood yeah even though dysfunctional
family and all this all right I'm out of
here I'm glad that I wasn't
immersed in this business so early on
yeah and that I had friends that walk
around our little neighborhood and cut
through yards and drink out of garden
hoses and catch fireflies and play
Wiffle ball in the backyard and be a kid
yeah and kind of get lost and just get
in the mischief and it just seems like
you didn't have that I did actually you
do have that and the job on top of it
like I had summer camps and I had my
buddies and I had my running around back
alleys and I had all of that okay but I
had and so it's you know to to be fair
to my parents I think they thought I had
a normal childhood
but applied on top of that was I was on
Broadway and I was doing eight shows a
week including two on Saturday and two
on Sunday and two on Wednesday how old
were you here uh I was on Broadway from
age 13 to age 17 every day wow
um
and then I was doing shows before that
and auditioning all the time and all
that from and I was doing commercials
and theater and stuff from like 10 to
13.
um
so that's like that's applied on top of
the normal life it's like you have this
life and then you have that thing on top
of the life so you know to to your point
like I think what saved my sanity was
that I had that alternative life but the
stressors of trying to manage both right
are very intense at that age yeah and
will bite you on the ass on some level
it's just inescapable do you think kids
when you start acting at a young age
it's beneficial in some ways because is
there a lack of
that sort of
anxiety ridden thing that we get as
adults the older we get we care more we
we're obsessed with being great we're
like when you're a kid you sort of let
things go that's why you see some great
child actors that are just awesome and
you're like how do they do that like
what's his name
Osmond yeah and you're like Jody Foster
or Elijah Wood or I mean Thomas
um I think that that I mean I wouldn't
presume to speak for anyone else but
myself because everybody's different but
I think that
um for me I actually had a love of stage
which is why my parents let me do it at
a really young age I was dancing I mean
my parents were dancers but they were
modern dancers so they weren't in the
industry at all like at all at all
um but I love tap and I love theater and
I love being on stage and I'm really
young I got on stage at like five six
seven so
but I was taking dance class at three
four five six
um gosh so I was like all singing all
dancing and they were like oh my God we
gotta get out of his way and so they
didn't want to not let me do it because
I loved it so much
um and that's different like when I when
I talked to other kids uh and I made a
documentary for HBO called Showbiz Kids
yeah talked to a lot of kids for that
and there were some you know
um who were just all singing all dancing
and it made sense and like if you're
their parent what are you gonna do you
know yeah um but it's a lot for the
parent if they're if once you get into
you know if you have some success
um and so to answer your question I
don't know how much it matters I think
that for me personally my trajectory you
know I was on Broadway I got hired by
Yul Brynner I was like working with very
high and people very young but I didn't
start studying intensely until my early
20s like I had actually almost finished
my career before I was like okay now I
want to really study
and wow I you know I'd gone through Film
School even I was like no I want to work
with like really high-end method people
and they went to NYU I went to NYU for
film I didn't study acting at all at NYU
um and so I came out and I was like
I just want to train and I just started
training even when I wasn't acting
professionally so I kind of rebuilt my
own craft later